100 premium combed cotton I don't know
what cone kind of mean but you don't
want the uncommon and Cone cotton right
here
[Music]
what's up GQ
dstv's rest of the channels and Montana
symptoms with GQ
[Music]
my team is from current cut
so you got to keep two pigs you know
what I'm saying food get stuck in
between
that's just what you do you get
permanent goals my mama bought me my
favorite Grill when I was my birthday
she got it for me 240 I remember
Tri-State Jewels I begged she brought me
that [ __ ] I lost it in the pool
probably came back at Kentucky Kingdom
like Kings Island
allow us to be trying to take it out of
hand someone could and the wave come and
the way
I can't really swim so I can't dive down
in the Deep being go find it it was uh
when you get a man you're gonna get
permanent it's kind of you know what I'm
saying it's like a status symbol I'm the
first person in Louisville though with
permanent diamond in my mouth
[Music]
jewelry box
she's like a light little travel box a
day like this is my ice box it's the
most recent one I didn't get ice box we
got some stuff I go to Iceman Nick
majority of the time
all right actually make this DSC piece I
recently had to watch taken or one of
one of the road he left in the hotel
room tripping it at the London
rose gold Prezi and so that's gone you
know to clean the lady ain't gonna say
she got that I respect it though you'll
see I know it's important they got my
mama
keep this area where what I was not keep
it my mom was speaking my mom would die
I don't know you see why I got the
little travel bag just make them so they
don't knock up against each other
I'm saying like the orange hair a little
woman
cute all my cubes kilos
little boy [ __ ]
oh man
and playing he's just some rings I got
right here
my brother he's in jail
and the face right this is his way
around him holding this one until he get
out of him where it is just so he can be
around you know I'm saying when I'm
doing [ __ ] I feel like
it's right there yeah see everybody
standing together my record label that
me and my friends started you know I'm
saying one of my favorite pieces from
ESC this is where you're gonna nobody if
the person don't know me by chance you
know what I'm saying they they look at
this and they kind of they kind of know
what's going on I'm not sure I'm like
350 grams so it there's some people's
chains and children that's 350 grams
total on something like just this right
here this this piece without the queue
it's 350.
with the 900 round Cube that's 1450 you
know what I'm saying and then these
earrings I can't really talk about these
big one who's the Allen Iverson
[ __ ] right here is what I call
in the answers I don't know I was in
Kevin Garnett they used to have big ass
earrings it's always if you want to meet
some big asses
[Music]
self-explanatory
need these to keep your stuff together
so I think it's going to transition into
the money prime example where we use for
[Music]
Advanced to make sure everything's neat
[Music]
I like the colors because I let me know
I might specifically put a certain
amount of money that it might be thought
off you know what I'm saying I don't
know if somebody be messing with my
certain color over bed and I'm like
interlock them a certain way so that
would take out you know I'm saying it
might break or something if you pull it
up a certain way so and this is
essential that's powered by this or
something it's easy
you might this might be a figure but
like
okay
each kind of play me the same thing so
go ahead and touch them I ain't gonna
know nothing
[Music]
I like coffee a lot like a natural
energy boost and I like black coffee I
think it's healthy or something
you know I'm being unhealthy
vegetarian
and I'm like oh
I'm the type of person like I ain't
sitting in no place to um
so if I'm at the store getting the
coffee
I don't got no time to be creamy sugars
and all that so I just got accustomed to
drinking them like that with nothing in
it black
[Music]
right here
boom
y'all be seeing me grab my five hours on
my black and man
it's like an energy boosts all day it's
like walking around with a cigarette
with a coffee cigarette
with energy come holla at me man I gotta
be the the biggest rap out of energy
advocate in the world right now I'm easy
zombie
[Music]
boom got to feel the chip like a man say
we somewhere like New York where it's
hard to get them you gotta get you one
of these classes hit black and red right
here with this little divot is this is
where they gluing the cancer paper down
in here a little brown paper here I went
down to the bottom and make the smoke a
lot more hot a harsh I'm making a lot
more chocolate smoke so we gotta loosen
the black up
oh so yeah let all that tobacco fall
into this packet right here this is the
classic rapper that the Black America
over there and I used to got that paper
filled up to the top of the back door
now I'm gonna take the tip of it
I'm saying loosen it up and take this
plastic tip off so we can get at the
look actually and then that little brown
paper on the inside I was telling you
about you know I'm saying I don't know
if you can kind of see it along the end
of the Ring boom I don't know why we
call it the Kansas papers because it's
what it's called it changed the smoke
though when you take it out like it's a
thousand times less harsh way smoother
you don't want to rip it so I don't know
what I'm saying all right get yourself
together
make sure it's an easy smooth pull out
boom see that right there
there's coming out that's the cam if
ever you want to take out the mega Hut
damn it real but it's supposed to be
like yeah but hold on I'm gonna get the
see that's why you got two sides if you
mess up on one
you can always go to the album so if you
rip while you pulling it out because
it's glued down
you want to take your straw I'm saying
really a regular slash driver
and put straight out
but then we're gonna take this
mount it back in here
I'm guts from Black America the tobacco
go back in there
all right
and you ready you got a black man
without the cancer stick on it
lighter
on the light again
[Music]
I used to feel like only petting these
had a lot of leashes but
then maybe I grew up in the game crazy I
don't know what happened sometimes you
ain't got no no no
Loops you know what I'm saying you know
jeans on
entire shorts up
and we're gonna look like not
however you gonna do it so they got that
little hook on it and then you take this
right here
hook it on your paint you let somebody
use the moon they hold it
it's coming back you know what I'm
saying don't let it just you know what
I'm saying pop hits you you know what
I'm saying you're gonna be actually
gonna hurt you know so make sure you
catch it back let it come back easy to
depends so it ain't going nowhere you
can let somebody use it and fear man
it's just attached to you
so this he's over like an eagle you can
let him light and everything he think
he's good I'm saying someone he's
sitting down he gonna feel like give
coming back to you he gonna let it go
boy you catch it man stop it Paul you
catch it right here wow and man
um it's a lot of you can keep a lot out
there
[Music]
Rich cotton man
[Music]
the world
so your local gas station if you're in
the hood
and it ain't no largest that's because I
came in I bought the whole wreck excuse
me a lot of people be like the collar is
too thick
but [ __ ] I got on you know staying pay
attention to the cows
what I'm saying gas station t-shirts for
the wind
[Music]
I know I buy the most airpods in the
world I buy
airport every time
I'm at the airport apart about
over a hundred paragraphs to shoot Pros
I like the pros
and whatever but all the noise
cancellation
I'll buy a new Earth every Earth chance
I get a highway to lose one okay when I
put them in my area might be on
playing whatever you know what I'm
saying it's like when you really never
go to sleep
you wake up everybody's gone you know
what I'm saying but I combined it don't
face me I'm buying another one I'm
saying that's an Enterprise for sure
right now everywhere I never felt
nothing you know what I'm saying go get
that right now if you haven't you have
appreciation I'll be right back at GQ
for my 50 most attractive man
I'm gonna tell y'all what place they put
me in I'm in the top fitting though you
know what I'm saying I'm upper they got
to going overseas and find some
different type of duper I'm the only
American I think I'm in South Philly so
what stock just went up
so I'm seeing everybody's own notice
but yeah escg everyone says
[Music]